Water has many amazing properties--
its surface tension enables things like bugs to walk across it without sinking
water also becomes less dense as it freezes
which is why during winter lakes freeze
from the top down and life persists at the bottom.
Now scientists have observed
a bizarre quantum-mechanical trick
in the smallest possible droplet of water.
Water's ability to form hydrogen bonds is
behind most of its extraordinary feats.
Water molecules are always bonding with
one another,
switching partners like dancers.
In order to study these bonds, researchers
performed low-temperature experiments on a cluster containing only six molecules--
the smallest droplet that will form a 3D shape.
By distinguishing the individual water
molecules in the cluster,
they observed a surprising result: Two different
molecules in the cluster move in sync,
breaking two different hydrogen bonds at
the same time.
The rotating molecules mesh like gears in a watch.
Here's where the weirdness of quantum mechanics comes in.
At the low temperatures used in this
experiment the molecules don't jiggle
with enough energy to even break one
hydrogen bond.
There is an energy barrier between the two configurations that's too high to scale.
But thanks to quantum uncertainty there's still a chance that the cluster will simply pop
through that energy barrier--a bit like walking through a wall.
That weird trick is known as quantum tunneling.
This unexpected cog-like motion in the tiniest droplet
shows once again how plain old water
continues to serve up scientific surprises.